[Musique]
les gens de pokémon arceus arrive à très
grands pas la dernière fois que nous en
avions parlé c'était en avril pour
l'annnonce du jeu en lui même depuis
plusieurs informations sont tombées
plusieurs thrillers et on commence à
avoir un aspect global de ce que va nous
proposer le jeu néanmoins ce nouveau
titre pokémon atypique nous cachent
encore bien des secrets normal j'ai
envie de vous dire on est encore dans
une phase de communication et de
marketing nintendo c'est très bien quoi
nous montrer tout en maintenant la haye
jusqu'à la sortie du jeu mais je pense
qu'il ya quand même moyen de déceler
certaines choses et c'est ce que l'on va
voir aujourd'hui dans cette vidéo pour
être tout à fait honnête avec vous il ya
maintenant plus d'un mois voire même
deux mois le broc ring couteau et moi
même avons imaginé une grande théorie
sur les gens de pokémon arceus mais de
peur qu'un récent trailer ne vienne tout
cas c'est tout dévoiler on a mis un
petit peu cette vidéo en stand by le
temps de voir les nouvelles informations
et cetera il s'avère qu'au final il n'y
a rien eu de bien fou ça a été surtout
des nouvelles formes des nouveaux
pokémon qui ont été annoncées et du coup
on estime que la maintenance et le bon
moment pour vous proposer
vision nos idées et c'est ce que l'on va
faire alors ne tardons pas bienvenue
dans une nouvelle théorie sur legend
pokémon arceus
mais avant de rentrer dans le vif du
sujet il faut remettre un peu de
contexte situé dans le passé eswi devenu
par la suite si nos est encore une
région inexplorée est inconnu du reste
du monde par le biais du groupe galaxie
dirigé par le commandant cormier nous
héros en tant que chercheurs auront la
tâche d'explorer eswi et de créer le
tout premier pokédex de la région tout
ce côté historique et notamment traduit
par la présence des ancêtres des
personnages que nous avons connu dans
les premiers jeux comme le commandant
cormier qui rappelle le professeur
sorbier la cheffe selena et elio risa et
viviane ou encore marcia qui est
l'ancêtre de mars bref voilà ça c'est le
pitch de base pour ceux qui ne seraient
pas encore trop familier avec ce nouveau
jeu néanmoins rien qu'avec cette base et
du coup les récent trailer il y a moyen
déjà d'établir certaines choses les
premiers éléments qui doivent nous
mettre la puce à l'oreille c'est que
nous nous retrouvons dans un si nos
anciens traduisant à côté historique
bien des films nous connaissons tous
l'air du présent de la région ses
légendes ses pokémon ses personnages son
histoire et pour ceux qui ne maîtrisent
pas tout ça les remakes de diamant et
perle sorte bientôt donc voilà il ya
clairement un désir pour les créateurs
que chaque fan possède les bases
concernant la région de sinnoh avant de
pouvoir jouer à ce nouvel opus et ce
n'est pas du tout anodin puisque un jeu
basé sur le passé d'un présent déjà bien
établis et connus se doit de respecter
son contenu et par extension son récit
et sa mythologie un respect qui est déjà
traduit par le biais des trailer nous
pouvons prendre l'exemple de la présence
d'autochtones dans la région disent oui
effectivement ce n'est pas parce que la
région est inconnu du grand monde
qu'elle n'est pas habité un lien
cohérent avec l'histoire du monde réel
et la colonisation le code vestimentaire
de ces fameuses autochtones est
d'ailleurs très particulier puisque ces
derniers arbore les couleurs et symboles
de dialga et palkia une symbolique forte
qui témoignent d'une forme de vénération
de la part de ces locaux en l'honneur
des dieux du temps et de l'espace mais
surtout cela implique la présence
d'éléments importants pour le jeu
puisque si dialga palkia sont présents
dans un jeu dédié à arceus dans la
région antique de sinnoh cela
sous-entend que d'autres éléments de la
mythologie et du lough seront là et cela
aura son importance vous allez
comprendre et pour ça il faut que nous
nous dirigions vers les inspirations
culturel de la série
maintenant que nous avons souligné la
présence du background instauré par la
quatrième génération il est temps de se
pencher plus en détail sur le contenu de
légende arceus pour définir certaines
choses tout d'abord il faut se pencher
sur les cas des pokémon monarque gardé
par nos fameuses autochtones c'est
pokémon nous sont présentés comme étant
doté d'un pouvoir mystérieux issu d'une
certaine bénédiction qui dit bénédiction
implique forcément la présence d'une
entité supérieure qu'ils octroient et
qui de mieux placé car qu'est us le dieu
des pokémon pour remplir ce rôle
le jeu étant à son nom cela fait sens
d'autant que nous pouvons apercevoir le
symbole de couronnes propre arcus
lorsque le nom de ces fameux monarque
s'affiche à l'écran de plus les
autochtones du jeu de par leurs
vêtements nous traduisent une certaine
symbolique puisque là où dialga palkia
sont les créations et les serviteurs
d'arqués us les gardiens qui ont choisi
de ressembler au duo de la création sont
au service des pokémon monarque des
pokémon doré comme arceus un détail
implicite mais qui possède son
importance mais également il faut
mentionner le fait que les pokémons
monarque peuvent être appelés à l'aide
de la flûte céleste et qu'ils viendront
ainsi nous aider dans notre quête des
pokémon monarque béni parquet russe qui
viennent nous aider ces mêmes pokémon
vivent à la base en harmonie avec les
humains et il y à même la présence d'une
flûte qui reprend les codes de la flûte
azur et qui produit la même mélodie
[Musique]
et d'ailleurs on peut mentionner le cas
du fameux ce marcus une sorte de
téléphone tout droit venu du ciel censés
nous aider à explorer la région si la
sonorité évident de son nom ne trompe
personne cette symbolique d'une
technologie avancée est liée au divin
est d'autant plus significative en
prenant en compte la tendance actuelle
dans le monde du jeu vidéo borisov the
wild nous introduisent est par exemple
la technologie chez cas dont notamment
sa tablette une technologie très avancée
dépassant de loin
le savoir du commun des mortels apportée
par la ds il y a par le biais des
chèques à et qui contraste avec le reste
du monde bref comme on peut le voir tout
ce qui touche à arcus nous démontre
qu'il n'est pas hostile pour les humains
à la base et qu'au contraire il
chercherait même à nous aider pourtant
c'est pokémon béni s'en prennent à nous
pour quelles raisons c'est un secret
pour personne l'univers de pokémon
regorge d'innombrables références aux
différentes cultures du monde réel si
les développeurs ont déjà pioché dans le
shintô isme afin de concevoir certains
monstres de poche légende arceus on le
cette fois ci elle est plus loin en
s'inspirant véritablement de l'histoire
du japon et de sa principale religion
pour la construction de son récit suivre
cette inspiration culturel nous
permettrait donc naturellement de
répondre aux quelques interrogations qui
gravitent autour de nos fameux monarque
il faut savoir que le shintô ismet une
religion particulière qui ne prient pas
de dieu à proprement parler mais des
êtres portant le nom de camille sée
camille se présente comme esprits de la
nature et en tant que tel incarnez
personnifie leur environnement seulement
si l'environnement qui les définit
venaient à être affectées alors les gars
me le serais également pour mieux saisir
ce concept bien particulier prenons en
exemple le cas de l'esprit putride dans
le voyage de chihiro celui ci se révèle
en réalité être un camille mais la
pollution engendrée par les nombreux
déchets jetés par l'homme dans la
rivière qui l'incarnent est à l'origine
de sa corruption véritable ode à la
nature le shintô isme cherche donc à
préserver l'environnement en respectant
les kamis puisqu'il existerait pour
ainsi dire autour de camille qui peut y
avoir deux rivières de forêt ou encore
de montagne les adeptes du shintô ont
bâti de nombreux sanctuaires aux quatre
coins du japon chacun canalisant le
pouvoir à camille ainsi si la corruption
venait à s'en emparer divers rites de
purification pour s y déroulait dans le
but de les apaiser commencez vous à voir
où je veux revenir
et pokémon monarque eux semblent tous
veiller sur un endroit qui leur est
propre à chaque acteur est injustement
désignés comme étant le roi de la forêt
plus encore ces pokémon sont révéré par
les habitants disent oui qui y ont
notamment désigner des gardiens en les
assignant aux endroits où se manifestent
délimité par des structures arborant les
emblèmes sacré de dialga et de pas le
cas ces lieux ne sont évidemment pas
sans rappeler les sanctuaire shinto vous
l'aurez compris c'est pokémon qui ont
reçu une bénédiction divine serait
l'équivalent des camille dans les genres
d'arcus et tout comme il est nécessaire
d' apaiser les esprits du shintô isme au
travers de rite de purification nous
devrons nous aussi veiller à pacifier
les monarques victime d'un phénomène
mystérieux qui les a soudainement
enrager ses pokémon autrefois révéré par
les humains à grèce désormais tous ceux
qu'il croise mais alors qu'est ce qui
peut bien être à l'origine d'un tel
phénomène ou devrais-je plutôt dire qui
donc a bien pu provoquer leur corruption
par rapport à tout ce que nous avons dit
et tout ce que nous avons démontré une
entité émane clairement comme
antagonistes
[Musique]
à l'origine de la mythologie pokémon
arceus est désigné comme l'être originel
né à partir d'un oeuf issus du néant il
a façonné le monde pour ce faire il
donna naissance à la matière dialga
palkia sont alors apparues afin de
réguler le temps et l'espace néanmoins
de cette engendrement naquit une
conséquence si le divin est parfait sa
création ne l'est pas si la matière
existent sont opposés également un
équilibre naturel qui se forme avec
l'antimatière et de cette antimatière
émergent guira tina et c'est à ce moment
précis que cela devient très intéressant
puisque le dieu des pokémon est le
créateur de la vie et de la matière
gears athina en est tout son opposition
et symbolise donc tous car qu'est us n'a
jamais souhaité par conséquent il ne
peut cohabiter avec ce qu'a établi
arceus et c'est la raison pour laquelle
giratina se retrouvent banni dans une
dimension où le temps et l'espace sont
perturbées maintenant en liaison avec
les jambes arquées us cela peut donner
clairement quelque chose d'incroyable
giratina est désignée comme un pokémon
renégat soit celui qui a renié sa
religion ce qui veut dire qu'il a renié
son créateur dans platine cynthia nous
apprend que le nom de guerre à tina est
enfoui depuis le tréfonds des âges comme
si ils avaient été cachés plus encore il
serait aussi puissant que dialga palkia
raymond la description du pokédex en
rajoute une couche en nous indiquant que
sa grande violence lui a valu d'être
banni il observe les hommes en silence
depuis le monde distorsion la matière et
l'antimatière ne devront pas se
rencontrer sous peine de tout annihilait
guira tina se présente comme
l'incarnation de cette pollution qui
ronge la nature et contre laquelle le
chine tourisme se bat tel un ange déchu
rejetée est enfermé dans une prison par
son créateur sa rancoeur ne fait que
grandir au fil des âges une rock heures
traduisant une violence et une
agressivité sans pareil souhaitant se
libérer de ses chaînes qui rate in un
temps très justement de corrompre les
différentes zones de la région dans le
but d'atteindre arceus en affaiblissant
le monde une corruption qui serait
notamment à l'origine de l'apparition de
pokémon di bao plus imposant que leurs
congénères et caractérisés par leur
violence ces derniers cherchant à nous
poursuivre sans relâche dès l'instant
qu'ils nous voient ces pokémon se
démarque des autres par leurs yeux d'un
rouge vif tiens donc des pokémon
violents aux yeux d'un rouge vif
si les humains et les pokémon vivre en
harmonie ce phénomène vient perturber
les équilibres de l'ordre n'aient le
chaos en menaçant et en effrayant les
humains leur foi envers arceus se
perdrait et entraînerait ainsi une
confrontation diviser pour mieux régner
que ce soit en termes de mythologie
d'inspiration culturel de cohérence de
l'univers ou de puissance si arceus
devait craindre quelqu'un ou quelque
chose ce serait bel et bien
keira tina
j'aimerais néanmoins ajouté un petit mot
si nous insistons sur le fait que
giratina serait l'antagoniste d'arqués
us la logique voudrait que nous ayons
également un antagoniste à l'échelle
humaine en effet puisque nous joueurs
incarnons un humain nul doute que nous
devront confronter une menace humaine
d'autant que ce ne sera pas avec gears
athina que nous aurions de grands
dialogues mais surtout si ce dernier
peut agir aujourd'hui alors qu'il était
enfermé dans sa prison depuis le fond
des âges c'est que quelqu'un ou quelque
chose est récemment venu à son aide le
commandant cormier pour beaucoup attendu
comme étant un antagoniste et pour cause
il est le leader du groupe galaxie dont
le nom est partagé par la fameuse team
aux actes néfastes dans les jeux
d'origine d'ailleurs le design de sa
tenue avec les manches flottante et son
code couleur nous rappelle étrangement
guira tina mais surtout si nous en tant
que joueurs avons en quelque sorte été
désigné par kargus pour lui venir en
aide et bien guerra tina pourrait lui
aussi avoir son champion étrangers
disent oui le groupe galaxie
contrairement aux locaux ils n'ignorent
l'histoire de la région qui de mieux
placé que des personnes ne connaissant
pas l'ampleur de la dangerosité de
guerra tina pour agir à son compte
enfin voilà c'est la fin de cette vidéo
et on espère sincèrement qu'elle vous
aura plu pour de vrai cette théorie a
émergé plutôt rapidement nocar guira
tina est vraiment l'entité parfaite pour
menacer eswi et arceus de manière
cohérente et historique a requis 7 ans
la star de son opus il lui faut une
entité capable de le confronter et qui
de mieux que sa création rejetée pour le
faire toute la symbolique derrière tout
ça est très forte évidemment cela ne
reflète que notre pensée et vous êtes
tout à fait en droit d'avoir une vision
totalement différente et je vous
encourage à nous la partager en
commentaire en attendant je vous invite
bien évidemment à aller voir la chaîne
de la mirin couteau qui est l'expert est
le théoricien par excellence de zelda si
vous avez aimé la partie influences
culturelles avec le shintô isme vous
serez scotché de voir ce qu'il peut vous
dire sur zelda merci à tous d'avoir
regardé la vidéo on a adoré la faire
c'était vraiment passionnant et puis bah
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la
chaîne a laissé un petit pouce bleus et
puis bah écoute et que lionheart soit
avec vous c'était argot rock allez ciao
tome
[Musique]